you know it's funny yesterday i was
really talking about how we're starting
to win we're entering this post woke
world there's a lot of good signs for
all sorts of things and so what's
unfortunate about what's just happened
and especially again because this has
happened because of a leak is that it's
going to sort of make us take our eye
off of some of the good things that are
happening say the mask mandates going
away say elon getting twitter
uh all the good stuff desantis fighting
disney et cetera et cetera
and we're gonna all be focusing on
abortion which is which because of the
existential issues related to it is
something that is insolvable in some
ways and intractable in so many ways so
it's good like the hate is just going to
start bubbling up again right it's back
it's back we have to acknowledge that um
but also what it's going to do is this
is going to mask a whole bunch of
disastrous
policy stuff that the biden
administration has uh been doing for the
last year and a half whether it's on
censorship covert or student loans we've
got a little compilation for you
um if not the mandate is not to
adjudicate what is true or false online
or or otherwise um
it will operate in a nonprofit person in
a political manner
it should not be lost on anyone uh that
uh there is a dire need uh for money uh
to continue to fund our needs uh on
covid on inflation um has the white
house analyzed at all how much that's
right student loan forgiveness would
impact inflation
i i know there's been outside analysis
of that but i don't have any internal
analysis at this point too
so those are just like three examples of
the disastrous stuff whether it's the
ministry of truth that they've now
started to put together so that they can
infringe on our ability to speak freely
and the first amendment rights or
whether it's just scaring us with more
covet nonsense or whether it's that they
want to take care of student loan which
just punishes people who actually paid
off their debt or for some reason you
want to pay off some rich kid who went
to
say syracuse for 70 grand a year you
want to pay off his 280 000 loan with
other people's tax money so they have
failed us at virtually every level right
but it's not just that
those few things we also have this
disastrous inflation problem uh and the
immigration stuff which is a disaster
and now this is all becoming a liability
for joe biden so it's suddenly like well
wait a minute if they feel they can fire
up the base with the abortion stuff
perhaps that had a little something to
do with the leak because the guy's got a
whole bunch of problems
it says that the president's poulter
of the alarm about inflation and
immigration becoming political
liabilities um coupled with this new
polling that is out today that shows
that voters
trust republicans more believe they're
more better that they are better suited
to handle both of these issues so can
you speak to how the administration is
digesting this data including these
remarks from the pollster and and is
there a sense right now that there needs
to be some kind of force correction on
these two issues given that polling in
the midterms being just six months out
well let me first say that um that
report was about um a range of polling
that goes back to last year um including
before
a number of events happened whether it
was the invasion
of russia into ukraine or even the um
the uptick of covet that we saw um late
in the summer and into the fall really
primarily in the fall okay so the point
here is the administration has disasters
at every level the war in ukraine like
just all of the stuff we all know this
inflation supply chain okay fine so we
have all these disasters all over the
place and one of the things that we now
know
for sure from polling and i can tell you
as a as a humble author who just went on
a book tour when i meet people out on
the streets and who come to my shows uh
i'm meeting a huge amount of people who
are now telling me dave i was a lifelong
democrat just like you i'm never going
to vote for a democrat again i'm not a
lefty anymore they either i'm a sort of
moderate conservative or i'm a
libertarian or a classical liberal some
some version of all that but but
wouldn't it be interesting if if the
leak
really was about scaring the [ __ ] out of
those people those people who have been
on the fence the bill maher types who
there's a huge swath of them there's a
huge swath of them they've been silenced
and they've been
cowed into irrelevance
but those are the people who could
decide the next election these sort of
disaffected liberals who have had it
with the progressives who have been on
their way
to say becoming conservative
republican whatever whatever phrase you
want to use on that whatever label you
want to use
but now this this thing comes out and
then that pushes them all back because
abortion is just such a freaking
personal
powerful issue